>> Monica Valentine: Good
afternoon and welcome.
My name is Monica
Valentine and I work
at the Library of Congress.
All day here at the Library
of Congress National Book
Festival we are recognizing
and celebrating the
importance of reading
and authors and books.
The Library of Congress makes it
seem easy to do this every year,
but the truth is, the
National Book Festival is a
huge undertaking.
It's a huge financial
undertaking and it is free
for everyone, because
of the generous support
from our sponsors
and supporters.
Spread the joy of reading
with your gift online
at loc.gov/donate
from the Festival app
or when you purchase
books today.
Now, on to the main event.
Erin Entrada Kelly is the author
of four critically
acclaimed books for
and about young people
including "Blackbird Fly",
"The Land of Forgotten Girls",
and her latest hit,
"You go First."
Please don't forget to
visit the book sales area
where her books are
available today.
This year, Erin was awarded the
prestigious John Newbery Medal
for her book, "Hello, Universe",
the story of four middle
schoolers whose lives intersect
in an interesting way.
I'm thrilled to introduce
and congratulate the 2018
Newbery Medal winner,
please welcome Erin
Entrada Kelly.
[ Applause ]
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
Thank you.
So, I'm going to talk for a
little bit and then I'm going
to take questions at the end,
so I hope you have questions.
You look super inquisitive.
So, I'm assuming
you do; no pressure.
So, one of the most
common questions
that I get is why
do you write books
and was in your inspiration?
So, I've answered
this in a variety
of different ways
that's pretty similar,
but to kind of give you an
idea of the answer to both
of those questions,
I'm going to ask you
to use your imaginations.
Does anyone here
like to daydream
or use their imaginations a lot?
Me too. Okay, so we're
going to turn it on, right?
And I want you to
imagine, okay and I'm going
to paint you a picture
because I write books
so I tell stories, right?
I want you to picture a girl.
She's twelve years
old, okay got it?
Twelve-year-old girl and
she looks a lot different
from her peers at school, okay.
Whatever you want
that to look like.
And let's say that she has,
well I'll give you a little
hint what she looks like,
she has very dark hair, okay.
And the other girls in
her school they have perms
like the ones that
make your hair curly,
because this is the
style at her school.
This may have been in the 80s.
Just a spoiler alert.
So, anyway the other girls
in her school all have
like light hair and perms
and she really wants to look
like them and they
have blue eyes
and she doesn't have
any of those things.
So, what she has done is this
girl that we're picturing
in our heads she has put
some spray in her hair
to make her hair kind
of blonder, okay.
It's called Sun-In.
I don't know if any of you
are familiar with Sun-In,
but you spray it in your hair
and it makes your
hair lighter, okay.
So, she's kind of got
like these blonde streaks
in her hair, okay.
And another thing she
did is she got a perm,
because that's what the other
girls were doing and she wanted
to be pretty like the other
girls, but the perm didn't;
I have to tell you the perm
did not come out that great.
So, picture with a very
bad perm kind of like hair
like everywhere, okay.
It does it on [inaudible].
So, now we're going
to give her a setting,
so that's our character
and she's also
by the way very quiet, right.
She's a daydreamer
like a lot of you.
And she's not very outgoing.
She has like one best friend.
You know, how some people have;
how many of you in here have
like a whole bunch
of best friends?
And how many of you just have
like one or two best friends?
Right? Okay.
That's the kind of
kid that she is.
She just has one best friend
and your best friend's
name is Nichole.
So, the problem with having
best friend when twelve
and in middle school, is
that sometimes your best
friend is not in your class
and that is the case
in her gym class.
So, our setting is
going to be gym class.
Who loves gym class?
A few people.
Okay, of the adults, how
many of you loved gym class?
You're like this is the best.
Okay, so as I suspected,
the majority
of the people do not
enjoy gym class, okay.
Some of you do, probably
people who know how
to like actually play
sports and stuff.
But our character,
our twelve-year-old girl she's
terrible at all sports, okay,
that's another thing
you need to know.
When I say she's
terrible at all sports,
I mean like when there's a ball
coming toward her face she ducks
as if her life depends
on it, okay.
Also, she can't throw.
So she throws something it
lands like two feet away
and it's sputters away, okay.
So, this is our girl
and she's in gym class.
Now, something terrible
is about to happen okay.
We're going to do some
more scene setting here.
You want to know the terrible
things that's about to happen
to our twelve-year-old girl?
The coach, Coach Reed is her
name, she says, "We're going
to play basketball today."
Okay, that's the bad
thing number one,
because by the way she's
terrible at basketball, running
and dribbling she doesn't
understand how that's possible
at the same time.
So, then the coach says, "I'm
going to choose two captains
and the captains are going to
choose sides for basketball."
Have any of you ever had that
happen to you in gym class,
the grownups and kids where
you have to choose sides?
You know what I'm talking about.
So, you're like the captain
and you say, "I want Sally."
"I want Joe", you
know how it goes.
So, when the coach
announces this,
our girl her heart
starts beating really,
really hard, okay.
Now, I have to tell you, she
makes a wish at that moment
and it's not a very nice wish,
because I have to tell you
that real people in books
just as real people in life,
you don't always have nice
sunny thoughts, right?
Because no one in here thinks my
thoughts all the time correct?
So, this girl has not
a very nice thought
and this is her not
a very nice thought.
Her thought is, "I hope
Jessica is picked last."
Now, who you're wondering
who's Jessica.
I'll tell you.
Every time in gym class when
the team captains choose sides,
there's always two girls who are
picked last or second to last.
One of them is our
twelve-year-old girl
and the other one is
a girl named Jessica.
Jessica is a perfectly
nice girl.
She's very, very shy.
She doesn't have many friends.
So, it's either going to be
our character or it's going
to be Jessica, right,
one of them is going
to be picked last, right.
And our girl character is hoping
with every ounce of her soul
that it is Jessica
and not her, right.
So, that's not a very
nice thought, correct?
Because that means Jessica
has to be picked last
and that she doesn't, she
doesn't have to be picked last,
but then it's Jessica
who has to deal with it.
So, the captains start
calling out names
and our girl is standing
there you guys.
And she's trying to act like she
doesn't really care, you know,
you've done that before
where you try to act
like you don't care about
something, but you do.
So, she's trying
to act very casual
because she's know
what's coming.
And she hears one name after
the other, after the other.
Now, her best friend
Nichole, you remember Nichole,
she's not in gym class with
her, because the best thing
that can happen when this,
this scene happens is
that you could be chosen
the captain, then you get
to choose the names, right?
The second best thing
that can happen is
that your best friend is the
team captain, because you know
that your best friend
doesn't care
that you're terrible
at basketball.
She's not going to let
you be picked last.
So, neither of those
things have happened.
So, she's standing there and
her heart's beating, okay,
names are called, names are
called and guess what happens,
she's picked last again.
And now she has to go out on the
basketball court and play a game
that she's already
terrible at and pretend
like she doesn't care when
all she can think about is.
"I was picked last and
everyone knows it", right?
Now, you're probably wondering
how this answers the question.
And the question was, if you
remember, "Why do I write books
and why do I write
for young people?"
The answer to the second
one is I'm going to let you
in on a secret; I don't
really like grownups.
No offense.
Kids are much more
interesting to me.
Grownups can be a little
boring sometimes except for me.
I'm fascinating.
So, the main reason though
is when I was a kid, okay,
here's another secret, I was
very lonely, self-conscious.
I always second-guessed myself
all of the time and the thing
that grownups sometimes
forget about being a kid is,
while you're going
through all this,
while you're being picked
last for basketball,
why you're sitting
alone at lunch,
while you're being left out,
while you're best
friend is talking
about you behind your
back, while the person
who likes you doesn't like you
and says something mean all
these terrible things are
happening to you, a lot of
times you feel like you have
to act like you don't care.
It doesn't bother you,
because you want to be, right,
you don't want to be the;
you want to feel like you're
in control of things
that are happening to you
and that things are just
rolling off your back, right?
You want to put on a strong
exterior and the problem
with that is a lot of
times we're putting
on a strong exterior, but
inside our hearts are breaking.
Not all the time and some more
than others, so what I want
from my books is for
the amount of time
that young people are
reading, that they feel
like they're not alone anymore.
Because the thing is,
when you're the twelve-year-old
standing in the gym class,
or the kid sitting
alone at lunch,
or the person being made fun
of, or the person who's weird
or being laughed at, okay,
when you're that person,
you can be in a room full of
people and still feel all alone
and like you're the
only person in universe.
So, in my books one common
theme that's in all my books is
that that's how the kids feel
and it's not a good way to feel,
but it's inevitable, right,
we know what inevitable means.
It's going to happen to
all of us at some point.
So, my hope is that books,
by the way, have you figured
out the twelve-year-old is me?
I didn't reveal that.
You saw that twist coming.
You knew it was coming.
Okay. That really
wasn't a twist was it?
You knew from the
beginning, okay.
I want kids to know that they're
not alone and I want you,
when you read my books,
to connect with the kids
that I write about, because
there's a piece of me
in all the kids except
the mean kids.
Those are based off
people I don't like.
Just kidding a little bit.
So, that's kind of my spiel
and one thing that's common
in all my books is
that it has characters
who are called "misfits."
They're called misfits a
lot; kids who don't quite fit
in who are trying to find their
place in the world which is kind
of all kids and all people.
And the idea that you
can be quiet, but mighty,
that you can be strong in
a lot of different ways
and that you don't have to be
the best student, the prettiest,
the most handsome, the most
athletic, the cleverest.
All you have to be is the best
version of yourself, right?
And that's the message that I
want my books to give to you.
So, all that being said,
guess what happens now?
You're bursting with
questions I can tell.
See, I feel like
if I say that ahead
of time everyone will
ask questions, right?
Because you don't want me to
be embarrassed, you just heard
that sad story, right?
Okay, so I will take
questions from people
of all ages unless you're
thirty-two then I don't
take them.
Just kidding.
Okay, are we ready?
Questions.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Question ]
That I ever wrote?
>> Yes.
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
Or that I ever read?
Okay. My favorite
book that ever wrote?
I have to tell you I was just
having this conversation earlier
and a lot of authors, if
you've seen other authors a lot
of times they say, "I
don't have a favorite.
I love all my books.
They're like my children."
You know, and they are,
but I do have a favorite.
It's my second book
and the title is
"The Land of Forgotten Girls."
That's my favorite
book that I wrote.
And the reason is because it's
about two sisters,
I have a sister.
Does anyone have a
sibling, siblings, yeah.
Aren't they fun?
Yeah, the people, the kids in
the front they're like "no."
It's about two sisters
who use their imaginations
to overcome their circumstances,
but I do love all
the books I've wrote,
but that one is my favorite.
I have an older sister.
She's okay.
Yes, question.
Oh! Oh there's a mic okay good.
>> Are your character's
personalities based
on anybody that you've met?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly: Yes.
A lot of times my characters are
based off; there's a piece of me
in a lot of my characters
and also the kind of person
that I want to be and different
qualities from people I've met.
Yes, good question.
Thank you.
Oh.
>> Why did you make all your
characters kind of misfity
as opposed to like,
like the average people?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly: Oh,
that's a great question.
I have a soft spot
for underdogs.
We know what underdogs
are right?
Underdogs are the kids
who are underestimated,
who don't know their strengths
and other people don't know
their strengths either.
I have a special place in
heart for people who go
against the grain and it's very,
very hard to be yourself
especially when you're young,
because you want to fit in
but then everyone's like,
all the grownups are
like "Just be yourself."
But then when you be yourself
other people are saying,
"Oh you're weird" or oh
you're this, oh you're that.
And so then you try to fit in
and you're not being yourself.
Anyway, it takes a lot of
bravery to be a misfit.
So, I have a soft
spot for misfits.
Great question.
Thank you.
>> How long did it take you
to write "Hello, Universe"?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly: It
took, all my books take
about a year to write.
So, with "Hello, Universe" I
had to do a lot of research.
So, I spent about six months
doing research and then
about six months writing and
then it takes another year
because you have to send
your book to your editor
and make revisions and they
have to do cover art, so a year
and then another year to
polish it off and get it ready.
>> How did you figure
out you won the Newbery
and how did you celebrate?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
Oh, How did I find
out I won the Newbery?
So, I have to tell you that what
happens is the Newbery Committee
for those of you who don't know,
they call you usually very early
in the morning, the day that
they announce the winners,
but they did not have
my correct phone number.
I think they had an old number.
So, I woke up and I thought,
you know, I didn't expect
to win anyway honestly.
So, I was like oh
I wonder who won?
And I'm driving to
work and I have
to act it out, I don't know why.
This is me driving
and the phone rings
and it's the Newbery Committee
and they tell me that I won
and I'm on my way to work and
they say, "You know you won."
And I said, "What?"
And then there's a big
long pause, it's on YouTube
because there's a
big quite pause
and then I ask like
what happened?
And they repeated it and I hung
up the phone and I called my job
and I said, "I'm not coming
in for the rest of the week."
And then, because
there's no way, right?
I mean, first of all I doubt
I would be able to concentrate
and then you have
all these interviews.
And then guess what
happens after that?
Like maybe this kind
of answers the question
of how I celebrated, like the
following week I went back
to work and I was like, "By the
way, do you remember last week
when I said I wasn't coming
in for the rest of the week?
Well, now I'm not
coming back ever."
Because I was able
to quit my job.
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Yes. Thank you.
>> Why did you choose
Scrabble for "You Go First"?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
Oh, great question.
Why did I choose Scrabble
for "You Go First"?
So, for those of you who
don't know "You Go First" is
about two kids who
compete in online Scrabble
and they have a friendship,
a long distance friendship.
The reason I chose Scrabble,
are you ready for this?
This is deep, okay?
Is because Scrabble is a lot
like life and you're saying why.
I'm going to tell you.
Chess is another game that's
featured a lot in fiction right?
But chess, those of you who
play chess, anyone play chess?
I play, but not well.
It's all strategy, right.
If you're playing
chess correctly,
it's not luck, it's strategy.
Scrabble is a mix of luck,
because you don't know
what cards you're going to;
not cards, tiles, you don't
know what letters you're going
to get.
It's a mix of luck and strategy
and to me that's kind
of what life is like.
Also, a lot of people are
familiar with Scrabble even
if they don't play it, so
it's a good game to choose.
Thank you, great question.
>> Do you remember one
of the first stories
you wrote as a child?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly: I do.
I still have them.
One of the first stories I wrote
is called the "Two Orphans",
but it was spelled
the "Two Orpans"
because I forgot the "h."
I also wrote a lot of
what we would call today a
"Sweet Valley High" fan fiction.
But mine was called
"Golden Valley Twins"
and they were brunettes.
So, it was original.
So, those were some
of my first stories.
Yes.
>> What advice would you
give to someone who's trying
to become published themselves?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
My advice,
my advice is any good
writer is a good reader.
So, you have to read voraciously
and you have to write a lot,
and also don't be afraid to
write something that isn't
that great, because you have
to get it out, practice;
just like with anything,
just like with any craft,
you have to work at it.
But the number one
thing is, to read a lot.
Yeah.
>> In your book "Hello,
Universe" one
of the character's grandmothers
Lola tells him lots of stories
to kind of stop him from taking
risks and being different
and I was wondering where
you learned those stories?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
So, Lola in "Hello,
Universe" is a Filipino
grandmother who uses a lot
of folktales to tell
life lessons
and she's modeled after my mom.
My mom loves to tell stories.
My mom is a devout Catholic.
She actually lives in a convent,
and when I was growing up,
she told a lot of
stories about the saints.
And I have to tell you, some
of you may know this already,
but Lola's stories
are very dark.
The lives of saints also very
dark, you know, there's a lot
of suffering and a
life lesson at the end.
So, Lola's stories are
secular but you know based
in Filipino folklore
and Filipino mythology.
>> As a kid did you
really like to write?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
I loved to write.
I started writing when
I was eight years old.
I loved it.
>> In your books like in "Hello,
Universe" did you write the
stories or did that Lola told
or were they like stories
that you found somewhere?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
It was a mix.
Lola's folktales are a mix
of actual Filipino folktales
and folktales that I made up.
Yes, great question.
>> Why did you decide
for Valentina and Virgil
to have the same initials
in "Hello, Universe?"
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
Oh, Valencia
and Virgil have the same,
because what I want you do
when you read "Hello,
Universe" is wonder if there's
such a thing as fate
or coincidence,
so they have the same
initials; is it fate?
I don't know.
That's for you decide.
We have a couple more minutes.
>> Will you ever write a book
from the bully's perspective
or will it always be
from the character
who is getting bullied?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
That is a great question.
No one has ever asked
me that before.
I don't know.
I don't have plans to,
but you never know.
That would be interesting
wouldn't it?
Judy Blume did that, my,
she's kind of my idle.
She wrote a book
called "Blubber" that's
from the bully's perspective.
It's one of my favorite books.
Good question.
Thank you.
>> Do you work on one book or
more than one book at a time?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly: I
work on one book at a time.
That way I can stay
focused mostly.
>> How did you decide to
write "Hello, Universe"?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
How did I decide?
You know what, I thought about
Virgil and I wanted to write
about a boy who was quiet
and shy and sensitive,
so we have a lot of girl
characters these days
who are very outspoken and
strong-willed like Valencia,
but we also need boy characters
who are shy and sensitive
and quiet and not
good at sports.
So, the story started
with Virgil.
>> What's a tip you
have for future writers?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly: A tip
I have for future writers;
I would say, don't give up,
that's good life advice anyway,
and read a lot of books.
>> What was your inspiration
for "Hello, Universe"?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
My inspiration is always,
I'm always inspired
by characters.
So, when Virgil came
into my head
and Valencia I was inspired
to tell their story.
Thank you.
>> What's your favorite
genre of books to read?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
My favorite genre,
oh my gosh that's hard.
I love scary books and
I love scary movies,
and I like, you know what?
I pretty much like all books.
I do like middle grade, I
mean that's what I write.
So, a couple of my
favorite books are
"The One and Only Ivan."
You've read that.
Yeah, Kathrrine Applegate
is here later I believe,
and also "When You Reach
Me" by Rebecca Stead.
Those are two of
my favorite books.
>> Do you think you're
pretty funny
or are you books mostly serious?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly: Do
I think I'm funny or what?
Curious?
>> Mostly serious.
>> Erin Entrada Kelly: Hum?
Oh, serious.
>> Are your books
funny or serious?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
Oh, my books.
Okay, because I'm very
serious and I'm funny.
No. You know, I would say that
they are a little bit of both.
I write contemporary, although
next year I have a fantasy
coming out, my first fantasy,
but all my books are
contemporary real-life.
So, it's about as funny as
real-life is [brief laughter].
Alright last question.
>> How many books
have you wrote?
>> Erin Entrada Kelly:
I have four books
out right now that
are published.
I've written mountains and
mountains, and one more coming
out next year and a
bazillion after that probably.
That's just an estimate
[applause].
Thank you.
I'm signing at 2, so
come see me alright,
and thank you for coming.
[ Applause ]